but if you could play casting director
on the show
what's the mix of girls you would like
to actually see on the cast
if you could pick everybody who's around
from seasons past present future we have
a great cast right now except for one
person I think I think only one person
on this cast doesn't seem to have
carried any weight this season and I
think that's very obvious who that
person is and I don't think that they
actually hit in the cast that well so
can you name names that well you know
there's just one there probably one of
the newest people on the cast right
maybe maybe miss Eva Marcille I don't
feel like either brings that much you
know it's really I'm just being honest
it's really when you look at a show like
everybody's out of the whole cast is
away and you don't miss the person at
all it's sort of like we didn't even
know you were here you know and all
season doing a lot of things from face
time but that's been the last couple of
seasons so I don't really see I don't I
don't know I don't know so if I if I had
to change I would change her and I bring
back someone from the past you said yeah
Breaking Bad someone from the past
I went brain came back but I know Kim
doesn't want to come back would you say
arlo into a full-time role there yeah
maybe slap Marlowe in there because I
don't really know anybody from the past
that's really interesting because when
they left because they pretty much
wasn't that interesting that's why they
been gone like ham is pretty interesting
so she's a good one to bring back if
Phaedra hadn't burned the house down
yeah they should be good one drink yeah
she hasn't burned the house down when
she was leaving so she can i yeah that's
kind of the bad thing about but I still
would like to see her come on like as a
friend of the show play around for a
couple of episodes because I still think
there's unfinished business there I
think it is unfair for the rest of the
cast to
people who they have issues with and
then she doesn't get to face who she has
an issue so the one time that she had a
real issue with somebody all of a sudden
they have to be off the show so I don't
think that part is fair and I think it's
okay for me to speak my thinking about
that kandi and I will continue to do
that it would be nice to get a little
check-in on her too because it's been a
couple years now her life is different
now yeah yeah it was great to see you
and Cynthia get to a place where you can
at least be friendly again because
people love that relationship love that
friendship
did you see the tick tock her daughter
did recreating the reunion site from
last year between you and Eva well I
actually didn't like something that you
say it myself
oh is that why we got the energy now
what energy is it because your energy is
real like raw today well Rock what do
you mean it's very aggressive aggressive
what do you mean I assume you're upset
about something about anything why
wouldn't you have banter with me that's
my point that it's like you're in your
feelings but beyond Andy what was the
question she said that she didn't like
it that you said Oh
between of all people me and Eva like I
couldn't people reached out to me asking
me you know did I see and that it's not
that serious me if it was a argument
with Eva it couldn't have been to me
interesting it couldn't we're really
learning how you feel about Eva you know
I don't have any harsh feelings towards
her it appears that she has harsh
feelings towards me
it proved it all season long with her
sitting in the car with Cynthia riding
rolling her eyes having all these things
to say as if I really did something to
her
maybe I stole her baby and I didn't know
it you know who knows who knows I could
anything happens with me you know
everything is so elevated so yeah
federal crime the person who actually
brought information on her which was
Marla so she walks around being mad at
me but I'm the girl who she's been
friends with for ten years and I'm like
a sister right
[Music]